14 members of a now disbanded Penn State
fraternity will stand trial even after a
judge dismissed the most serious charges
connected to a pledges death sophomore
Timothy Piazza died in February after an
alcohol hazing ritual inside a Beta
Theta Pi House on Friday involuntary
manslaughter and aggravated assault
charges against eight members were
dismissed four others had their charges
dropped altogether Jim Axelrod spoke to
the parents of Timothy Piazza after the
ruling Jim good morning
well good morning Friday's ruling was
not what Tim piazzas parents were hoping
for the most serious charges have been
dropped against the Penn State
fraternity members and the remaining
charges carry little to no jail time but
piazzas parents say they are looking
forward to the trials ahead and think
this is far from over the individuals
and in that fraternity were reckless in
their behavior and basically caused on
our son's death seven months after
sophomore Timothy Piazza died at a Penn
State fraternity initiation event his
parents say they are preparing for the
next steps in their legal battle we want
justice absolutely on Friday the most
serious charges including involuntary
manslaughter were dropped against eight
former Beta Theta Pi fraternity members
four had their charges dropped
altogether but 14 of the men still face
misdemeanors including alcohol and
hazing charges on February 4th Piazza
was at the Beta Theta Pi House for an
initiation event that involved heavy
drinking security video from inside the
house reportedly shows Piazza stumbling
and hitting his head repeatedly no one
called 911 for hours
Piazza later died from his injuries my
prayers go off the Piazza family former
fraternity member Joseph m's had his
reckless endangerment charge thrown out
I feel ready to get back to my normal
life I feel ready to go and see my
family and not have this weight on my
shoulders anymore what do people need to
understand
about what happened in there and how you
feel about your role people need to
understand is that this was a terrible
terrible tragedy and that's what it was
simply Timothy piazzas parents say the
important thing is that members of the
Beta Theta Pi fraternity will still
stand trial I'm looking forward to see
you know the trial and and whatever else
comes out of the investigation really
antenna facing hazing charges and that's
important to you
absolutely it's important why because we
need to put a stop to it it has no place
in Greek life the county prosecutor said
she plans to seek a judge's permission
to refile the involuntary manslaughter
charges against the former fraternity
members but their defense attorneys say
they will challenge any effort to
restore the dismiss charges dates have
not yet been set for the trials your
heart just still aches for the Piazza
family oh no winners anywhere in this
factory exactly Jim thank you